[Music]
open for in-person classes or stick with
remote learning
that's the difficult choice colleges are
facing as the fall semester begins
a number of prominent colleges and
universities have already welcomed
students back for classes only to
reverse course because of covet 19
outbreaks
colgate university in north central new
york has managed to open its campus
and keep it open so far after some
careful planning
errol barnett went back to school to see
how the university is trying to stay
safe and stay in session
you're not coming back to normal you're
coming back to a new normal
that's brian casey's message to the
returning 2500 students
at colgate university in upstate new
york we are outside
lawrence hall to bring them back the
president of the two century old school
has an unprecedented plan so you enter
you have to come
immediately to the right where a machine
will instantly take your temperature
and this camera is using infrared
technology to detect
and assume your temperature yep so every
classroom now
shows you the physical distancing
patterns and then you can see that all
the chairs have been pulled six feet
apart
so only nine students at a time in a
room that
probably would have had 20 to 22. wow
so this is a small lecture hall where
you can see that the seats have been
blocked off
but more importantly you see a camera
off to our right that as the professor
moves
the monitor the camera and the monitor
move with him so for those who are
watching
from home remotely they're getting the
whole classroom experience
casey decided against all remote
learning and instead structured a
reopening plan with advice from
medical and scientific experts the key
a mandatory two-week on-campus
quarantine
as step one all learning is initially
virtual
meals delivered straight to student
storms and time spent outside
scheduled colgate's faculty and staff
are also undergoing routine testing
why do you think this might be the
safest approach all of our students will
be tested before they show up
upon arrival and during the quarantine
toward the end
so we will know at the end of those 14
days that
any student coming out will have had
three negative tests
within a normal period in which the
disease exhibits itself
awesome it's a secluded community
alex didn't have a chance to return home
to vietnam when covet 19 closed the
school in the spring
the international student has been
living on campus ever since
and supports the quarantine what do you
say to other students
who are fearful in coming back to campus
i think uh the fear is totally valid i
myself am very nervous about
everyone coming back how risky do you
feel it is for you to be on campus
i actually think it's less risky for me
to be on campus rather than returning
home
marianna lemon is willing to make
sacrifices
for the on-campus experience the
freshmen from the bronx
moved in over the summer i still want to
have a freshman year and i'm still here
and i'm like honestly willing to like
always be in my room and just take
classes
online from my room and only talk to my
roommate and maybe
have like the social distance lunches or
dinners kind of deals outside when it's
still warm
out so i'm willing to like have like a
alternate
freshman year if that's what it takes
the students we spoke with
admit the lack of socializing will be
difficult when you're apart you're not
building that kind of connection that
you would have when you're here
especially for a linebacker on the
school's football team
aj desantis says team building is the
point
that's one of the most important things
in football because it's not one guy in
the field at that time it's many guys on
the field guys working together special
teams offense defense everything
together
if there's one thing we've seen
nationwide from georgia tech to the
university of north carolina at chapel
hill and usc
it's that college students will still
socialize in large groups
despite the risk leading those campuses
to either
shut down or quarantine infected
students
casey has a plan for that too we're
doing waste
water testing the virus exhibits itself
in wastewater often before you see it in
your mucus
or or your blood really yes so we have
put
readers wastewater readers on all of our
residence halls
all of the houses on broad street where
a lot of our students live
so if we detect any increase
in the virus which you'll see first in
wastewater we will immediately test
everyone in that particular house how
much is it costing you to do that
millions of dollars
we purchased a hotel so we have a
quarantine
site millions in the singular or we
approaching
10 million we are below 10 million three
rounds of testing
rapid testing machines all of our dining
halls had to be completely retrofitted
to
grab and go extra staff to do the
testing
you know we're north of four million
dollars right now that's a lot of money
just
out of out of pocket so you want this to
work i want this to work
so much so president casey is currently
living in a dorm room himself
neighboring his students for 17 days if
i'm asking you to do this
i'll do it too so whatever food you're
eating i'm going to eat whatever rules
you have about when you're allowed
outside that's when i'll go outside so
i'm doing it with them
no special treatment are we supposed to
believe that i'm the college president
the fact that i have a single known
bathroom strikes people is a real real
plus
and the president's r.a alex he'll be
staying in
my floor in my building so it's a lucky
coincidence
are you going to lay down the law if you
see the president break the rules
yes i am not afraid to have that
conversation
okay we will be following up okay
casey acknowledges the living situation
he's asking students to go through
isn't ideal but in our new world he says
it's essential why is that an important
point to make
because in our culture we rarely talk
about public good we rarely talk about
sacrificing individual needs
for benefits that accrue to everybody
that's not part of our political
rhetoric it's not part of our culture
anymore
so we want to tell them this is going to
be hard and that
they need to learn to think about not
just themselves
but other people and i think we're an
educational institution why don't we
make that something they're learning
this year why don't we make
that the lesson for cbs this morning
saturday
errol barnett hamilton new york i
like this guy this guy gets it and he
walks the walk doesn't just talk to talk
right look a lot
life is about choices and that's what
these students are facing right now if
you want to be
on campus here's an option yeah he might
get it it doesn't mean all 20 year olds
yeah
always get it without a doubt it's yeah
it's tough we all admit
socializing is part of the right you
know college experiences
as americans we forget freedom is is
oftentimes not free and with it comes
great responsibility
so kids let's learn